about social Norm bias residual harms of
furnace aware algorithms East is joint
work with my awesome collaborators Adam
right there Myra who's right now PhD
student at Stanford and now the time was
an intern at MSR and with Lester
and this is work that we published
earlier this year
so when we're talking about algorithmic
furnace something that I don't need to
mention to this group we're talking
about or measuring some form of this
priority across sensitive groups on a
measure of Interest
and when we're applying bias mitigation
approaches based on these definitions we
have different variants for these
strategies primarily we have
pre-processing in processing and
post-processing so these are all
different ways of enforcing certain
metrics of interest at a group level on
algorithms that we're developing
and this type of group foreigners
approaches have been very popular in
deployment because they're very easy to
implement and this is especially true
for post-processing algorithms that
don't require any retraining and this
has computational advantages but it also
has a lot of organizational advantages
if you're at a company and you need to
change a lot of different stages of your
pipeline is much harder than if you want
to say okay we're going to keep
everything the same and then we're just
going to implement the change at one
stage
so
at the center of this work is is
algorithmic group fairness enough
and so when we're talking about
sensitive groups when we're talking
about group furnace typically
the sensitive group that we're concerned
with actually this actually corresponds
to a social construct that is very
complex and it has multiple dimensions
and we're taking kind of a reductive
definition when we're saying we're going
to treat this as an indicator function
of do you belong to this group or do you
not belong to this group
and we're not the first ones to point
this out there is a lot of really
interesting research that has pointed
this out and has given us guidance of
how do we reason about this right in
philosophy of AI there's been a lot of
really interesting work on this uh Lily
and isa's work has given us very strong
critiques on what are the limitations
when we take this type of reductive
definitions and these also relate to
whether we're doing an ideal theorizing
of fairness right
so
what motivated us was saying okay can we
identify concrete harms that we're
living out when we're taking these
reductive definitions
and this is different than saying well
is there also an individual notion of
fairness that we may be concerned about
this is saying we decided that we're
concerned with fairness with respect to
a certain group this is with respect to
a social construct are there types of
harms that relate to that group in
particular that we're living out are
these type of are there these type of
residual Harms
how can we measure them
and then once we have measured them
another question that we were interested
in is
any algorithm that is taking this type
of reductive definitions we having the
same type of residual harms or using the
same
reductive definition can we actually
have different types of residual harms
four different types of a bias
mitigation approaches like the ones I
mentioned at the beginning
so we're going to focus on gender today
in particular and so as I said when
we're talking about gender
we typically say okay we're gonna have
an indicator function that we're gonna
use as what gender do you belong to but
this is a much more complex social
construct
there's an educational toolkit called
the a gender bread and so this gives us
a
kind of simplify representation of the
multiplicity of gender right so what
this shows us is when we're talking
about gender we're actually talking
about a lot of different things
and this is not saying that we need to
think about a multi-group actually
because this is not saying well we're
gonna think about your all of these as
different uh group memberships and then
we take the indicator function and
that's it right when we're thinking
about well is your gender expression is
it feminine is it it's not a binary it's
not that you say well you are feminine
you're not it's much more complex than
that right so this is the context this
is what I mean when I say that we're
taking a reductive definition
and uh generally when thinking about
algorithmic arms and algorithmic
injustices I like rounding this on
Research that has been done on
discrimination in the absence of
algorithms right and in the context of
the workplace there's been a lot of
research and organizational Sciences
Madeleine Hillman's work for example on
the role of descriptive and prescriptive
stereotypes in workplace discrimination
and so what descriptive stereotypes tell
us is that there are when there are
certain attributes that are or certain
behaviors that are thought of as being
part of a certain identity then adhering
to those stereotypes we can this is not
a frame they don't necessarily frame it
in terms of stereotypes but we can think
of it in terms of stereotypes if you
adhere to that type of stereotypes then
that can lead to discrimination when the
membership in that group is thought of
to be a poor fit for a given occupation
so let's say in many of the women in CF
workshops that you go to they tell you
well whatever you do don't bring
cupcakes to the office right and it's
similar to Devastation well should I
have worn a dress today to give this
talk so that is what it means to have
descriptive stereotypes that are
operationalized towards discrimination
and just as an aside there's also
prescriptive stereotypes so it doesn't
mean that if you adhere to the Norms of
the majority then you're okay because if
you deviate from certain behaviors that
are thought of that you ought to follow
then that can also be a problem like if
you're too volleyball then you may be
bossy and things like that so but what
we're concerned with here is just a
script of stereotypes all right so we're
thinking about descriptive stereotypes
there's a lot of research in
organizational sciences that have talked
about this
and so the question is do algorithms
exhibit these and are we mitigating them
when we apply bias mitigation approaches
based on the Notions of group membership
that we use
and so to do this we Define what we term
social Norm bias that are the
associations between an algorithm's
predictions and Conformity to social
norms
and so some of the concrete questions
that we ask here are to algorithms
exhibit social Norm bias
is these bias mitigated by group
fairness approaches and so
in other words if for example I am
there's an algorithm a bias mitigation
approach that is being applied to
something that I am being subjected to
can I benefit from that bias mitigation
approach more if I sound or act more
like a man right
and the experiments that we'll be doing
will be
egg grounded on the biasing BIOS task
and data set that we collected a few
years ago where this here the task was
can we predict someone's occupation from
their online biography and so thinking
about the role of algorithms in the
workplace and algorithms for recruiting
and hiring
the simplest task that an algorithm can
solve is what is your occupation if I'm
going to use your website to decide
whether I Target you with an
advertisement for a job
can I tell which job should I be
targeting you with
and so this is an example this is when
we did this earlier research on biasing
bios this was my biography at the time
and so here for example it would predict
that I'm a teacher right and so
these data set has approximately 400 000
online biographies and it is collected
in a way that we know what the
occupation is from the 28 possible
occupations from the Bureau of Labor
Statistics which are very variated
ranges from professors it's actually the
most common one which shows you both
that us professors really like having
our biographies online and also the fact
that maybe the regular expression that
we used to collect biographies was a
better fit for the one way that we write
okay our biographies and we also have
other occupations like yoga instructure
Physicians surgeon and so on
so this is the example that will anchor
things in but before that I'm gonna move
to how do we measure the inferred social
norms so
we have by the way any questions so far
but any of
them so we can delve into measuring
infrared social norms so as I said we
care about social Norm bias and so the
first question is what are the social
norms that the algorithm may be
inferring and so to do this we estimate
we build a predictive model that
estimates the probability that you
belong to a certain group and so we have
a prediction of How likely you are to
belong to a certain group
and then once we have this prediction in
the tag case where the class that we're
predicting is binary
then we can take a set that is the for a
given group for the individuals in
agreement even in a given group and
belonging to a certain class then what
is the prediction that we're obtaining
for the main task that we have let's say
predicting someone's occupation so we
have four individuals for women who are
surgeons what is the predicted
probability that we have that they're
surgeons and then we also have a set hey
we have we have the set of the predicted
probabilities that they are so this is
based on the pronouns and as an outside
the original data that I showed you had
only binary pronouns in this second uh
in this follow-up we did an additional
analysis where we did some manual
assessment of biographies that were used
they as a pronoun and we manually
verified that they were a referring to
an individual and not to a group so we
extended it to non-binary pronouns but
I'll be primarily focusing on the
results for women here and so
we have these two sets and then here we
can measure the correlation between
these two sets of predictions
what is it that this correlation tells
us what this allows us to answer is
whether the predictions of a central
tasks that we're concerned with
such as predicting someone's occupation
correlate with inferred social norms the
inferred social norms are norms that can
be inferred from the data set that is
being used to train a model
and so in the context of predicting
occupations for instance what this tells
us is whether the likelihood of
correctly predicting someone to be in
their occupation is correlated with how
feminine or masculine they can be
inferred to be based on the data set of
biographies
we can also extend this to the
multi-class setting where we have more
than two classes and this is something
that is necessary for the tasks that
we're focused on here we have 28 classes
right and so what we have here is we get
an added step so we have
the same two sets right now we just have
a sub index here because we have a given
class we have the correlation between
these two and then we have a set of
correlations right so this is Four Women
in each occupation what is the
correlation between How likely they are
to be perceived as feminine or masculine
right and then How likely they are to be
predicted to be in that occupation
and then we also have the percent the
fraction of the data in this class group
set
and so there what we can do is we can
measure the correlation between these
two okay
so the first question to ask is well
I've been talking about inferred social
norms
is there any relevance to the inferred
social norms they not need they don't
need to be corresponding to social norms
and so if I were to infer social norms
that have nothing to do with the way
that Society is structured then
maybe that wouldn't be harmful I'm just
correlated with some random thing that I
learned specific to this data set that
is not really at risk of compounding any
harm right so the first thing that we do
with this data set is look at
what is it that the algorithm is
inferring as its social norms
so to do this we take
we have the algorithms and so we have
weights for each word so here we're just
looking at a representation of the word
in this case this was a
waits for it uh for the word embedding
and so here we're looking and here this
is the genderness from Human label words
so this is from this work where they did
an annotation experiment where people
said okay how gendered is this word
right
so what we see is that there's a very
strong correlation between these two so
the Norms that the algorithm is learning
are very correlated with existing social
norms
the reason why then this matters is
because if the algorithm then is making
predictions that are correlated with
these social norms then it means that we
are at risk of compounding certain
Heights right and it's interesting to
see like some of the anomalies here so
for instance this is child here which
naturally the word child itself is not a
very gendered world word but in the
context of biographies it turns out that
women are much more likely to mention
their child in their biographies and so
it is gendered in what the algorithm
infers to be social norms in the data
set of biographies
so yes these word embeddings are coming
from bios from bios yeah from bias
[Music]
from our
right and so we're saying okay in
predicting that someone belongs to this
group right why is it how much weight is
it giving to each word right so what
we're seeing here is words that are
higher up are words that are the
algorithm infers to be more masculine so
more predictive of you're likely to be
using male gender pronouns in your
biography
and at the bottom of the y-axis are
words that means that the algorithm is
going to be more likely to predict that
you're using
she as your pronouns in your biography
in the x-axis this is a separate data
set that was human labeled and so this
is what humans perceive to be like how
gendered humans perceive to be this word
it is perisive to these words to be so
basically we take the subsets of all the
data of all the words that were labeled
in this human annotation and that's what
we're seeing in the dots and then we
take from all of those words which are
the ones that appear in the Bios which
most of them do because the data set is
pretty big and that's what we're
visualizing here
and so here we know that
they inferred social norms have some
meaning
and then there's a risk that if we're
making predictions that correlate with
this then there could be certain harms
but are we making predictions that
correlate with these
so this is what we look at here
so here we're seeing the percentage
of a biographies and occupation that use
she as their pronoun
and so that's what we're seeing in the
x-axis in the y-axis what we're seeing
is the correlation that I described
before so the correlation between the
likelihood that you'll be predicted to
be in a certain group and the likelihood
that you will be correctly predicted in
your occupation
an important thing to remember is that
this is just for the subset of people
that are in that group in that
occupation right
so if there was no correlation we should
be seeing things lying on a horizontal
line here what we see is very different
we see that there's a correlation here
so this is the measure that I mentioned
for the multi-class measurement and so
what we see is that
the strength of the correlation
increases with the occupation's gender
imbalance
and how what the direction of that
correlation is determined by what is the
predominant group in that occupation
right and so what this means is that How
likely I am to predict that you're a
surgeon is correlated with how masculine
do I perceive your biography to be
so an example of social Norm bias in the
context of algorithms would be the word
empowerment is a word that the algorithm
Associates to inferred feminine social
norms and so if a woman surgeon uses the
word empowerment in her biography then
the algorithm is less likely to classify
her as a surgeon
so now the question is is there
something that we're mitigating when
we're using bias mitigation approaches
that operate at the group level
so we compare multiple bias mitigation
approaches ranging from a pre-processing
multiple improcessing approaches and
post-processing approaches
all of the ones that we're plotting here
are operate at the group level we also
played around with a couple for example
which is an approach that we propose a
couple of years ago that doesn't
directly use the groups and so what
we're seeing here is the same plot that
I just showed you right so basically the
less correlation that we have here the
better right we want these things to be
flat
and so there's a number of things that
we see in these results
the first is that this type of gender
correlations can persist even when we're
using Fair aware interventions right so
the fact that we're mitigating things at
the group level doesn't mean that we're
mitigating these type of bias but the
different approaches are very very
different from each other
and there's a number of things that are
worth noting here
the first one is that post-processing
doesn't mitigate this type of bias at
all so I don't have here plotted there
like the initial approach but it's
because it's exactly overlaying with
post-processing which makes sense right
in post-processing the whole point is
that we're not changing the within group
ordering and what we're measuring here
is directly
deriving from within group ordering so
the issue that is happening here is if
we first learned a classifier that has
social Norm bias meaning your likelihood
to belong to a certain class is
dependent on how much you're adhering or
deviating from social norms of the
majority group in that a class then post
processing is not going to fix that at
all
the other thing that we see is that
other approaches do mitigate it some of
them quite a bit but it's not something
that follows this is something that
again is intuitive because if what we're
saying is for instance with an
improcessing approach we're saying I'm
going to penalize you if you have you
make a prediction that results in
certain types of Errors then I'm nudging
you to use another signal and so that
different signal that you're using for
prediction May yield better results in
terms of social Norm bias
the key there being the element me
so
expecting something
yes
perceived social law
this is first processing in this case
so the challenge there would be how do
you define the multiple dimensions of
the construct as multiples right because
if you're thinking about feminine or
masculine it's much more of a spectrum
than whether you're feminine or
masculine
you managed to be
here right you do have a definition of
perceived social norms I'm saying the
same thing can be penalized for that
correlation you mean yeah
specifically
find the same social norm
and many other potentials
[Music]
yeah so there's two parts to that so
part of it I think the answer is
potentially yes
there's a number of risks there and so
if we look at what we're doing here
right so what we're saying is Well we
could directly penalize this correlation
right because so the question of welcome
we just split there's a number of things
that we could think about learning here
one is just well let's split our notion
of gender into multiple groups and then
let that be okay that is pretty
challenging because it's not very easy
for you to say okay for this biography
do I place them as feminine I was like
right it's a bad definition of the group
itself would be challenging the only
thing that you're saying is Well you
don't need to Define that group right
you can just direct the penalize for
this measure if I'm understanding
correctly what I'm saying is that you
can Define
the group not once a thousand times
make sure that
whatever notion of fairness he wants to
be thousands of not
one of the characters
yeah and I think that one bit that you
could do there is doing those
for example like here what we're doing
is we have a prediction for whether you
belong to a certain to that group one of
the issues if you were if you were to
just analyze for this one correlation is
that obviously you can have a different
model that predict you may be just
predicting like penalizing for a certain
type of signals so if you were to do it
with a bunch of different predictors
right and so you could think of it as a
a predictive multiplicity setting in
which you say well we're gonna take a
set of predictors of belonging to this
group and then we're gonna Define all of
our groups based on that set of
predictors then I think that it would be
probably like the most direct way of
finalizing this I agree yeah that's a
very cool idea
and so here we see okay post-processing
doesn't mitigate it at all in processing
can mitigate it but it is not a given
right we really do need to measure these
explicitly
and so to summarize there's a number of
things that we have shown in this
research
so we've shown that algorithms May
display social Norm bias and so these
are the type of bias that we should be
concerned about and well the advantages
that we see here is that this is giving
us a very concrete way of measuring and
characterizing one of the residual harms
this is not the only one but one of the
residual harms when we consider
reductive definitions of social
constructs
and then
we see that post-processing quality is
really really popular and often we think
about well as long as we're penalizing
the measure of interest to the same
degree you we can just choose whichever
why would we choose improcessing why we
choose post-processing let's do the one
that is easiest this is this is giving
us a clear differentiating factor
between the different approaches and in
many cases a clear justification for
when we may actually want to incur in
the cost of retraining
and finally we see that group fitness
approaches May Avail certain harms and
hopefully here we have one approach to
measure one of those harms and I can
imagine future work looking at what are
other types of these residual harms and
exactly as you were saying what are ways
in which we can improve our bias
mitigation approaches one of the good
things here is that we see that once we
measure these sometimes we actually do
pretty well even when we're starting off
from a reductive definition of fairness
of the group membership and with these
I'll pause here and take any remaining
questions
[Applause]
the word logical
that was prescribed as like I think
environmentally
um and what I was wondering is that I
mean some maybe so they can
you might want the word logical in your
so like requiring deep correlation in
this case maybe it would harm your
predictor I love this question because
this allows me to talk about something
that I left out of the talk because I
didn't want to pack too much but yes
that is a really important question that
is if the word a engineer is presented
as muscle and well I still want to use
the word engineer to predict that you're
most likely an engineer and so we did a
second variant where we looked at task
relevant and task irrelevant words and
then we give the same approach on those
and so we have we had a way of looking
at basically what are words that are
predictive of the occupation
across the different genders and then
whatever words that are not predictive
of the occupation and then taking just
the set of task irrelevant words and
then Building G
here based on just the test irrelevant
words and so here you could have the
representation X that you're using being
a subset of your original X so that
you're excluding the task relevant
features that's a great question yeah
obviously for this setting it seems
steering appropriate to respect this
type of group ordering do you think
there's like realistic current settings
desirable like if the bias is sort of
I'm thinking of this paper by John
Feinberg where they're saying like the
bias affects the group uniformly so you
want to respect the recorder
um again not this setting but do you
think those are realistic settings I
think I think the question is what is it
so
there are no
no respect the group ordering but the
question is what is it that is being
that is being captured in your group
ordering right and so whenever the issue
that we're having is that we have a bias
through correlated features with your
group membership then the likelihood
that you're ordering is perfect is I
think something that we ought to
question a lot more than we usually do
because we usually say okay it's just at
the group level that we have an issue
but within each group we bet that the
predictive relationships that we're
using are the ones that we care about
and so I think that this it hopefully
shows okay what is the type of a
predictive relationship that are that
I'm using that leads me to have a group
ordering that I don't want to have thank
you
let's take the rest of the discussions